for the last week sloviansk has been
shelled every day and the russians are
moving closer the city's market was hit
firefighters did what they could to save
what they can at least two people died
[Music]
the occupying forces shot about 30
cluster munitions in the direction of
slovan's city which detonated over
various parts of the city
some of the shells hit the territory of
the central markets as well as in other
neighborhoods lobiansk is russia's next
big target taking the city would put
them within touching distance of control
of the whole of the donbass region and
that became their main military
objective after they failed to take the
capital kiev at the start of the war
the area's governor says it's time
for people to get out
there about 350 000 citizens who stayed
here in the region that's compared with
1.6 million who lived here before it's a
very significant quantity
despite what people say i do care about
their homes and their lives but they
should leave
this is what it looks like after the
russians target your city this is
kharkiv just 40 kilometers from the
russian border these apartment blocks
were home to half a million people one
of europe's largest neighborhoods
now there is little that is livable or
savable
manyakantula
i didn't see anything for a month i laid
there in the basement
thanks to the neighbors they gave me
something to drink
my wife is dead
those who survived are stuck nowhere to
stay nowhere safe to go
in his latest national address president
vladimir zelinsky warned of the
relentless nature of their enemy
the russian army does not take any
pauses it has one task
to take people's lives to intimidate
people so that even a few days without
an air raid warning is terrifying
chance fell to the russians on sunday
the signs of battle are all over the
city seizing the donbass region made of
luhansk and donetsk is the russian
priority and it appears they're
committing major resources to get it
done quickly alan fisher al jazeera
keeve